hi und willkommen zu vlogmas Tag 3 ja es
ist so ungefähr 15 Uhr wir wollten ein
bisschen früher starten aber wir hatten
gestern noch andere Pläne
guck mal so viel schöner wir sind mit
Freunden zu einer Restaurant
Neueröffnung gegangen also das
Restaurant ist basically einfach nur
umgezogen es ist so ein Italiener wo die
immer hingehen und was soll ich sagen
der Abend war feucht fröhlich
ne haben wir mal ein Ausschnitt
hier und
da schön ja ich war auf jeden Fall sehr
verkart aber ich kann mir immer no nicht
vorstellen warum so viel zu trinken
hatte ich gar nicht ich glaube ich habe
sehr wenig gegessen über den Tag also
passt auf mit Alkohol seid vorsichtig
das ist was ich sagen möchte aber
trotzdem lassen wir uns von unserem Plan
nicht abbringen denn wir haben heute was
schönes vor es ist der 2 Dezember aber
wir waren nicht ganz faul wir haben
nicht gechillt die pude aufgeräumt komm
mal mit also hier schon mal Schlafzimmer
toll das Bett ist nch nicht gemacht weil
ich die Bettwäsche wechseln möchte in
unsere winterliche weihnachtliche
Bettwäsche ja sieht natürlich super aus
aber gar nicht weihnachtlich ne hassen
wir brauchst du Licht boah
ne und dann kommen wir jetzt ins
Wohnzimmer wir haben zwar schon da
hinten ein Adventskalender von Timo und
hier und da eine Kerze aber das ist ja
auch noch nicht weihnachtlich ne und ihr
kennt mich ich bin eine kleine
Weihnachtsmaus ich bin ein bisschen
traurig dieses Jahr weil wir also ich
freue mich dass wir wegfahren wir fahren
ja für 10 Tage machen so eine kleine
Weihnachtstour aber deswegen können wir
uns kein Weihnachtsbaum holen weil wenn
wir jetzt heute z.B ein Baum holen
würden was ich sehr gerne tun würde ja
ist halt erstmal 10 Tage alleine und wir
wissen ja Tannenbäume sind Rudeltiere ne
die müssen die dürfen nicht alleine
gehalten werden eigentlich nicht ne nee
genau deswegen aber aber Timo bevor wir
die Wohnung hübsch machen mache ich mich
erstmal hübsch mit der Hilfe von
Holzkern jetzt si toll aus ne
amaz guckon mal wie toll jetzt mein
ganzer holzkernschmuck zur Geltung kommt
und meine Uhr
Timo das ist eine Handtasche ja aus Holz
aus
Ahorn dem Baum und da drin ist veganes
Leder ist sie nicht das schönste was du
jemals gesehen hast die nehme ich mit in
die Schweiz verrückt dass die aus Holz
ist aber die ist überhaupt nicht schwer
die Leute von holzken werden sich das
auch angucken sagen die hat das nicht in
ein pinguinpulli gemacht wenn ihr es bis
jetzt noch selber nicht gemerkt habe
holzkenen eignet sich einfach so schön
als Weihnachtsgeschenk du hast total
unique pieces alles sind Einzelstücke
weil sie aus Naturmaterialien
hergestellt werden also ja keine Perle
kein Holz gleich dem anderen und das da
oben drauf ist pmut und das ist Holz und
das ist natürlich sieht es immer anders
aus und deswegen sind alle pieces immer
Einzelstücke und wenn jetzt gleich auf
den Link unten in der Infobox klickt
weil ihr es kaum aushalten könnt und
euch die weiteren wunderschönen Teile
bei Holzkern anschauen wollt dann
vergesst nicht meinen Rabattcode zu
benutzen Leute ich habe einen Rabattcode
malwanne 15 für 15% bis zum 31.12 könnt
ihr das Einlösen und holzcen garantiert
eine Lieferung für alle die bis zum
20.12 bestellen also falls ihr das Video
gerade ein bisschen später seht oder
euch noch nicht so richtig entscheiden
konntet bis zum 20.12 aber macht's
früher Leute spart euch den Stress
besorgt früher eure Weihnachtsgeschenke
das ist auch hier man sieht in dieser
Wohnung noch gar nicht dass Weihnachten
ist das ist total deprimierend man sieht
nur die Löcher in der Wand
hinten ja scheiße wir ziehen bald um wir
hatten uns eh überlegt das ist wirklich
sehr kontrovers wir hatten eh überlegt
ob wir überhaupt dekorieren wollen weil
wir ja schon so in SE bis 8 Wochen
umziehen und da wir lieben diese Wohnung
nicht mehr wir wir wir wollen uns das
hier nicht mehr cozy machen wir wollen
hier alles einpacken und verschwinden
du weißt wie unser Keller aussieht ne
wie unser Keller aussieht ja das weißt
du scheiße sieht a oh mein Gott nein si
hormäßig a sieht horrormäßig aus wir
kommen nicht mal an die weihnachtskisten
ran aber wir sortieren echt viel
Weihnachtskram auch aus weil manchmal
manche Sachen davon habe ich teilweise
schon 10 Jahre 10 Jahre ist nicht lange
Zeit
eigentlich so jetzt gehen wir den
dunklen Keller wir project
mäßig
ja geh
[Applaus]
[Musik]
auf Luft rein ich das Licht
an
jetzth natürlich mal wie dunkel
ist bekommen
du bist der Tonmann warum hast du dir
selber kein Ton musst du mit dir selber
guck dir das doch
[Gelächter]
an gar nicht
[Musik]
rein
ich wünschte jemand könnte jetzt gerade
kurz pausieren unser Leben und das Weg
klicken und alles verkaufen oh mein Gott
das wäre so ein Relief Alter ich will
auch gar nicht ich bin eich ganz froh
dass ich die Kamera gerade halten
muss
durchschlagsübung kämpf dich einmal
durch vor allem alles voll
kalt aber ganz lässig mit einer Hand in
der Tasche machst du das wie so ein fer
der sich so ein bisschen zu cool
fühlt
ja gut ich fange mal an eben ne ja gut
mal hier das noch da ne
okay Dasch okay hey komm lass mal lass
mal lass lass lass mal lass mal jetzt
lass mal lass mal jetzt was ich hole die
Sachen jetzt
wie hallo let me do okay aber dann
kriegst du auch den Ton
warum wir gehen rein
Leute mus ich noch kurz warm machen
stört das das ist eine ganz klassische
ich quetsche mich erstmal unter
Schmerzen rein
Taktik nee diesen Schlitz hast du extra
freigelassen so jetzt sind wir unserem
Punkt angekommen von hier aus wird
gearbeitet das ist unser working area
ich würde mal sagen wir fangen an mit
der ersten Kiste die ist
praktischerweise auch schon relativ gut
in
Griffweite
[Musik]
was ist das hier ah leerer Karton cool
noch mal ein leerer Karton ja wow hier
die
Gelande was ist mit der Gelande hier die
hat ich doch geholt letztes Jahr alter
die wickelt sich hier einmal durch den
ganzen Keller durch die hatten wir da
oben weißt du wo oh mein
Gott peinlich der Keller Alter der ist
normalerweise immer geputzt Leute ne
ausnahmsweise heute mal ist
der die Kamer auf meine
Augen ja sehr
[Gelächter]
gut W ich sagen haben wir den ersten
Schritt
erledigt und wir gehen wieder
[Musik]
hoch bisschen erschöpft ich hab so
leckere Sachen bestellt was hast du
bestellt drei
Brötchen das sieht Original
aus du so irgendwie eingebrochen oder
wär so ein Tier was irgendwie dar
gefunden hatwi man hat
lichtemacht wir haben Waschbär bei uns
im in den Mülleimern gehabt Nachbar hat
uns ein Video geschickt von dem waschbän
der in unserem Mülleimer rumgewühlt hat
also nicht hier zu Hause sondern unten
die weiß heute noch nicht aufgemacht
haben Adventskalender und wir haben auch
ein richtig coolen Adventskalender von
timus Mama bekommen türch Nummer zwei ne
das ist ein paar Adventskalender und das
sind dann so Holzkarten und die sind
personalisiert na ja und dann gibt's
jeden Tag eine neue Karte und gestern
mussten wir uns sagen in welcher Fantasy
oder Geschichte oder Film wir uns gerne
auch kennen würden und zusammen sein
würden und jetzt kommt Türchen Nummer Z
all die Entscheidungen die man jeden Tag
treffen muss das kann doch ganz schön
anstrengend sein oder kein Problem heute
macht das die Münze für euch nehmt euch
eine Münze magischerweise kam jetzt hier
eine Münze stellt die erste Frage wie
z.B was machen wir heute jeder schickt
eine Option ins Rennen z.B zu zweit
Kuchen essen gehen oder im Wald
spazieren gehen ich würde sagen wir
sagen wer muss gleich die
maultächlesuppe machen wenn sie da ist
ja ich sag du du ich sag du also du oder
du
okay ach so nimmst du Kopf oder nimmst
du Zahl nimm Kopf dann nhme ich zahl
nein bis unser Essen jetzt kommt werden
wir schon mal anfangen zu dekorieren und
wir schauen erstmal wie es meinem
plastiktannenbauen gehen die letzten
Jahre haben wir echte genommen früher
hatte ich nie einen echten aber ich
glaube zweimal hatten wir jetzt ein
echten oder aber weil wir dieses ja
nicht so viel da sein werden lohnt sich
wirklich kein
echter das sehe sogar ich
ein na wie schön findest du
es ganz einfach zack h ist der
klein aber irgendwie
cute
bist du bereit für die erste Kugel des
Jahres ja was ist dieses Jahr die erste
Kugel des Jahres ist so lecker ich habe
jetzt so Bock da reinzuweichßen die ist
aus New York na ja guck wir müssen Licht
dran machen ich glaube ich erstmal ganz
kurz mein Eis auf oder und dann machen
wir weiter freust du dich eigentlich auf
Weihnachten Timo ich freue mich extrem
ja ich freue mich jedes jahrf muss ich
sagen schöne Zeit ja ich B einfach jetzt
mal rein ne irendwi ist ein bisschen
[Musik]
traurig guck mal und kannst du das bei
einem echten tanbaum machen nein
so okay probieren wir
[Musik]
aus ach komm das sieht doch nett
aus also W hier nicht weihnachsstimmung
kommt dem kann man nicht mehr helfen so
dann kommen wir jetzt mal zum schönsten
Schritt bei der ganzen Sache und zwar
die Kugeln aufhängen das hängen wir mal
den Waffen hier auf da kommt da mal als
erzt kommt da mal hängt da jetzt mal so
Muffin ein bisschen schwer für
dies wir hab so heavyight
an guck das Teil
an Leon guck mal dein Burger hängt hier
haben wir von Tim Schwester
bekommen schon Akku alle da ist so eine
Lichterkette drin und Federn voll schön
ne hier sind jedes Jahr ist irgendwie
schön ne jedes Jahr holen wir die wieder
raus für ein Monat sind sie dann toll
und dann B er wieder weg
oh der Budha m
importante was für ein Schmuck habt ihr
eigentlich an eurem Baum seid ihr wie
wir so Sammler von Gegenständen und so
Erinnerung oder habt ihr immer so ein
Farbkonzept das wird mich mal
interessieren und wenn ihr schon mal da
unten seid dann könnt ihr mich auch
abonnieren ich möchte eine Million
abonnenten haben von wem haben wir den
denn unsere
lieblingskugel auch Geist ist krank
schwer hier fällt mir erst auf wie
schwer diese ganzen Kugel sind das ist
meine älteste Chris Kugel die habe ich
mir bei butlas gekauft als ich nach
Berlin gezogen bin und ich nee wo habe
ich sie ja bei B aber nicht als ich nach
die ist ungefähr 10 Jahre alt oh oh das
ist mein Favorite die habe ich mir
geholt die hast du ausgesucht wenn wir
irgendwann Kinder haben dann dürfen die
sich auch immer überall chrisbaumkugel
aussuchen hab ich auch New York geholt
ne London London jaond in diesem krassen
Haus weißt du da mit in der Stadt London
ist so eine heftige Stadt London ist ja
für mich immer so die Weihnachtsstadt
gewesen also da gibt's ja die schönsten
Lichter und alles sieht einfach
wunderschön aus und dann habe ich bei
also für unserecherche für unsere Reise
habe ich dann recherchiert und habe
gelesen Mailand soll genauso so eine
weihnachtliche Stadt sein ich kann mir
nicht vorstellen dass sie mit London
mithalten können aber es gibt ein
Swarowski Tannenbaum hast du das schon
gehört Leute ich muss dieses Jahr zu
diesem Swarowski Tannenbaum aber nach
Kalender denke ich kann der TAN auch
nicht so gut werden ja das ist nämlich
das Ding oder die schmeißen mich raus
die sehen mich schon von beiden das ist
sie ja ich häng mal hier ein bisschen
weiter auf und dann zeige ich euch
gleich das
[Musik]
Ergebnis ja ja warte nee nee ich muss es
nach hinten hängen dass es dann den Baum
bisschen nach hinten zieht wei weß du du
bist gerade ne da dann knck nach da Was
ist schon gerade auf der Welt was
verläuft gerade nichts so Tannenbaum ist
fertig ja wir haben dies eine kleine
abgespeckte Version ich weiß nicht ob
ihr euch noch an den Tannenbaum vom
letzten Jahr erinnern K war so riesig
der war so riesig der stand ja da und
warte über als es war
geisteskrank oh mein
Gott was ist denn das jetzt ich habe
noch nicht von
draußen Schatz das ist zu groß als
nächstes möchte ich euch noch zeigen wie
ich das Schlafzimmer umgestalte weil ich
finde das Schlafzimmer hat immer den
meisten Effekt also klar hier steht der
Weihnachtsbaum und so aber wir machen
jetzt unsere winterliche Bettwäsche
drauf und ich wechsel sogar die Gardine
weil ich habe eine in rot und ich finde
das ist natürlich schön zu Weihnachten
rote Gardinen zu haben dann lass uns
einmal rüber gehen ich kann nicht mit
dieser Situation ich finde die Kamera
sieht so nach 2017 aus hey Leute hier
ist wieder eure malwanne und willkommen
zu diesem Video heute rede ich über
nichts und ma jetzt Dings bist du bereit
ein richtig cozy gemütliches
Schlafzimmer zu habens absolut du weißt
aber auch dass wir dann wenn wir heute
Abend ins Bett gehen dann machen wir
irgendwas Weihnachtsfilm an oder so bin
ich sowas von ready dafür diese
Bettwäsche ich weiß dass das schon
wieder Taus mal in den Kommentaren
stehen wird die ist natürlich von
[Musik]
Ikea
nichts schreit mehr Weihnachten als
fliederbettwäsche mit schottischem oder
hei es schottischen Muster die kommt bei
uns auch nur im Winter
raus so
he es jetzt ein
Bett wow kann man kaum
glauben wo ist denn die
Leiter ah das geht ja einfach
so
verstaubt die ist ja richtig
verstaubt ja das wird doch nett aussehen
mein Gott es wird ja
weihnachtlich
so
das ist do
jetzt gemütlich alte Gardinen Weg auch
gewaschen werden aber es ist so krass ne
in der neuen Wohnung werden wir keine
stangengardinen haben sondern die an der
Decke ich habe so viele Gardinen über
die letzten 10 Jahre angesammelt die ich
auch alle noch schön finde wo ich jetzt
richtig traurig bin dass das ich einf
nicht mehr benutzen kann weil die halt
Ösen haben braucht jemand Gardinen mus
noch ein riesen Flohmarkt oder so machen
wie wir heute entdeckt haben wir lieben
Fake Tanne und das ist
unser Jam und hier auf dem Tisch
Alter mein
Gott let's
go stop stop
stop
[Gelächter]
renentiere
h wie entscheidet man wo Deko hinkommt
wo nicht welche Dings was ist das
eigentlich was ist eigentlich dekorieren
für eine komische Sache das ist einfach
so total intuitives hinstellen und da
sieht's dann besser aus als woanders ich
dekoriere jetzt mal zu Ende und dann
zeige ich euch das
Ergebnis
[Musik]
Merry chrmas
Baby R is coming out
play Santa CL is in the
[Musik]
dieses Jahr habe ich mich wirklich
zurückgehalten mit der Deko ich glaube
auch ich muss einiges aussortieren was
wir gar nicht mehr in die neue Wohnung
mitnehmen wegen dem Umzug bin ich jetzt
nicht so sehr mit der Deko ausgerastet
weil ich auch irgendwie nicht also ne
aber ich glaube das Ergebnis lässt sich
sehen ich fühle mich sehr wohl und es
ist jetzt richtig schön christmasy hier
ne und es ist auch wichtig glaube ich
vor so einer Reise noch mal richtig
aufzuräumen damit die Wohnung wenn man
und dann wieder nach Hause kommt sich
richtig gut anfühlt und man nicht in so
ein Chaos reingeht morgen müssen wir
packen und morgen zeige ich euch auch
mal alle Adventskalender die ich habe
weil ich habe ein paar mehr und dann
kann ich euch die mal
vorstellen ja und dann sehen uns morgen
ne Leute macht's gut ich wünsche euch
einen schönen Tag abonniert meinen Kanal
lasst ein Daumen nach oben da Timo hält
das Licht gerade in seiner Hand das
sieht fantastisch
aus und du singst auch langsam runter
geh V auf die Schultern Alter woh so
klein
ist